hello wordsmiths I have to keep my voice
down you see you've caught me observing
a word in its natural habitat here we
can see the words at play nominalizing
and conjugating brachiating snoozing
there's a waterfall of
vowels there's the conate
bamboo all of this together all the
words and the situation in which they
live it's one Big E
ecosystem let me let me right let me
back
up ecosystem is the word we're looking
at in this video
eois it's a noun it means all living and
non-living things that are found in a
specific environment so if this Forest
I'm in is a rainforest we're talking
about everything in that rainforest
birds and monkeys and bugs and Vines and
mosses and rocks and rivers all of it
together is an ecosystem let's talk
about this word's derivation Eco is an
interesting prefix because now it means
having to do with the environment but It
ultimately comes from the Greek oos
meaning home or Dwelling Place the Earth
is our home is the thinking there system
comes to us from Greek too and it means
the whole thing together basically it's
composed of word parts that mean a thing
that sticks together so an ecosystem
right is the way a home an environment
works all together as a single unit the
fish eat the bugs and the bugs pollinate
the plants and the plants feed the
monkeys the monkeys distribute the seeds
a system an ecos system you see so with
these two word Parts Eco and system what
can you come up with what words can you
assemble let me give you 10 seconds and
we'll meet back here after a quick music
break all right here we
go
here are three I came up with ecology
this is the study of natural
environments logi logg Y is a suffix
that means the study of like biology is
the study of BIOS bios life neurology is
the study of brains and ecology is the
study of Eco the oos the house that we
all live in called planet Earth economy
this is the common word that plays on
that same oos route because this word
has to do with money right uh but
originally it had a meaning more like
household management the economy is the
way business behaves for a whole country
right how's the economy doing but it's
playing on the idea of a household
budget how much was a dozen eggs this
week how much was a can of coconut milk
a jar of peanut butter and systematic
methodical doing something efficiently
applying a system to how you do
something let's say I'm systematic about
making breakfast sandwiches maybe I'll
bake a whole tray of eggs and cut them
into squares and put them on the little
buns I got a system I'm being
systematic and let's be systematic about
teaching you the meaning of ecosystem by
using it in a sentence or two in a
Pacific kelp forest ecosystem sea otters
eat kelp hungry sea urchins this is the
sort of environment it is right it's an
undersea forest and it's not just the
kelp it's everything present there from
the algae and the sand and the rocks and
the seawater to the living creatures you
have to back up and see all of them
working in
concert it's all connected here's
another one vultures provide an
essential ecosystem service by eating
Carion by eating dead things I realize
now that my vulture looks more like a
Dodo I love the like fluffy rough that
vultures have at the base of their necks
anyway vultures are contributing to the
functioning of the ecosystem
by eating carrying you're a part of it
too by the way you're part of an
ecosystem of of Learners and knowledge
and rocks and Moss and vultures and
Otter and sea urchins and bugs and
monkeys you're connected to it too and
may that knowledge give you strength you
can learn anything daveid out